alaa girthy être and for the next half
hour we're pleased to have New York
Times columnist marine Dowd here before
her panel and to take your calls as well
marine doubt how do you view your job
well Peter that's a good question I
don't like to talk about this because it
sounds a little corny I view my job as a
watchdog and Times readers often don't
understand that I'm not an ideological
columnist I'm not coming from the left
or the right I I was a political
reporter for 20 years and so I come at
it more from a political reporting point
of view I'm just going to try and tell
them I'm going to it's like todo pulling
the curtain and The Wizard of Oz I'm
going to try and give our readers
anything I can find out that they need
to know about you know what is true and
what is false and what these people who
are going to have life-and-death power
over us or really like and where they're
lying and where they're you know rising
to the occasion and marine Dowd's most
recent book is called the year of voting
dangerously the derangement of American
politics how many u.s. presidents have
you covered do you know well I I started
I covered the very tail end of Reagan
when he was on his way out I did a few
features on him and actually I went on a
trip with him to an Asian economic
summit and covered Nancy because in
those days if you were the woman you
covered the woman so I covered Nancy
Reagan a bit I did an interview with her
where I failed to ask the most of the
most important question but I failed to
get the right answer which was are you
superstitious and she said a little and
knocked on on wood but it was really
Formica in the plane we were in and then
it turned out she was running the entire
Russia relationship with her astrologer
deciding everything about whether we
would you know have nuclear or harm
reduction so I kind of missed the big
story there but I started there and then
I was the White House report
for the first president Bush and a
little a year with President Clinton and
then I got a column in 95 but I kept
covering president well you suggest in
the year of voting dangerously that you
and president HW senior should have
couples Council no I think his aide
suggested that it's a wonderful Jeanne
Beker
it is like a screwball comedy I wrote an
essay in the book that I'm really proud
of an original essay about my thirty
years you know covering the Bush family
and the letters that the first President
Bush has written me over the years I put
in the essay and it's a very unusual
relationship because he wasn't
he's like a wasp from Greenwich who was
taken to kindergarten in a chauffeured
limousine and I obviously am from a
working-class ethnic background and I
think he was expecting the New York
Times reporter to be like Clyde
Farnsworth the third and they would have
martinis and discussed the Atlantic
Alliance and you know he got something
quite different but we came to
appreciate each other over the years and
he represents the kind of civility that
may be gone from our politics for good
he sent you literally hundreds of notes
yes he did and you know as he himself
says these are not notes that would be
like John Adams or Thomas Jefferson
letters where historians would mine them
you know they're more kind of fun notes
complaining about the lives that the New
York Times and um who we likes and who
he doesn't and trying to get me to be
more conservative and listened to my
conservative siblings and it's all about
what he calls our love-hate relationship
but he's really not a hater so he's you
know but he has a really wacky sense of
humor I would compare him to Tom Hanks
and in in Big where he is like a boy
bursting out of an adult body in
when he was the ambassador to China he
or the representative in China the
Chinese used to say he had a personality
like dance on a hot pan just very I mean
he's the opposite of low energy job job
should have had some of that energy
well marine doubt is our guest and if
you'd like to call in and talk with her
the numbers are on the screen 2:02 is
the area code 7 for 8 8200 for those of
you in the east and central time zones
two zero two seven four eight eight two
zero one if you live in the mountain and
Pacific time zones
we'll get to those in just a minute
what's your relationship what was your
relationship with George W Bush it was
it was good in the beginning I had an
interview with him when he first
announced stuff in the Kennebunkport
compound and he liked me because I had
given Barbara Bush a good review in the
New York Times for her memoir which was
really fun you know
Barbara's very sort of fiery Greenwich
granite Peggy Noonan called her and so
it was fine at first but then
unfortunately I think he went down a
very bad path with a rock and came under
the sway of the man I first I think I
was the first to dub Dick Cheney Darth
Vader although then he began calling
himself bad very proudly and now Steve
banning calls himself that so I think
the relationship with all the press
corps got more tense as they kind of you
know had fake news about the Iraq war
marine down in November of 2008 and this
is in the book the Year voting
dangerously you write about the White
House how can such a lovely house make
so many of its inhabitants right well
this is you know a lot of my friends are
really hysterical about the Trump
presidency
and one of my girlfriend's is a health
nut we to be mission lives in San
Francisco she said to me oh my gosh you
know I'm having a glass of wine a day
now and I try to reassure them and say
don't worry you know we've had a lot of
crazy presidents and modern history and
Lyndon Johnson's aides used to argue
about whether he was a manic-depressive
or a clinically paranoid you know JFK
and Nixon took psychotropic drugs and so
yes the presidents at the very moment
where they should feel affirmed and
confident that the American public has
put them in the seat of power often you
know they're gremlins their insecurities
come out instead and so you know Nixon
was walking the halls talking to the
paintings and doing a lot of crazy
things and so what are they so yes you
know we've had we've survived a lot of
crazy presidents already so of course
we're going to survive one more do you
think Donald Trumpkin
quote-unquote drain the swamp or change
Washington culture I think it's up in
the air you know he he has a point in a
lot of people sort of from the swamp but
it remains to be seen whether like Joe
Kennedy you know they appointed Joe
Kennedy to the Securities and Exchange
Commission because he was the Fox in the
henhouse he knew that he knew because he
had you know broken the rules himself
how to catch people breaking the role so
like the best hope is that that's what's
happening with Trump's appointees that's
because they know this they will help
you know figure it out but you know I
don't I wouldn't sanguine Lee say that I
expect that to happen I'm just saying
we're not sure yet read out in your
column you expose a lot of yourself and
your family and their don't you yeah
I do because I called them my little
basket of deplorable because I come from
a conservative family and you know my
father stayed up all night the night
Truman was elected he was so excited he
worked in the Senate he was a police
detective and you know he knew Truman
and loved him and so my parents were up
all night excited about Truman on the
night Trump won my brother was up all
night excited about Trump so the
Democrats have to figure out how they
lost you know the working-class ethnic
vote and what they can do to get it back
your sister Peggy Dodd has a has a
chapter in your book she does this is
the first time she's written I let my
brother write the column once a year
because I think it's really good I think
New Year's times readers really enjoy
getting in the belly of the red-state
beef you know and hearing how they think
I think that both are better about
hearing how conservative thinks and
conservatives just want to hear
themselves echoed endlessly and so I
asked my sister to write an essay
because she has an amazing political
history she was at JFK's inauguration
because she loved JFK she wasn't even
old enough to vote yet she was 18 and
then she or can you vote at 18 Canoga
not back then no no a big change that
all right so then she she loved Bobby
Kennedy and was at the Ambassador Hotel
the night he was assassinated and then
she fell in love with w and volunteered
at his 2000 convention and she didn't
she couldn't get a room in Philadelphia
so she came to my room and said could
she stay with me and I said you can
command but the sign that says w stands
for women cannot come in mother
and then she got disillusioned about the
Iraq war and decided to vote for Barack
Obama and then she got disillusioned
about President Obama and sort of
briefly became a socialist with Bernie
Sanders and then she went to Cubans fell
in love with Che Guevara
and became a communist for a weekend and
then she decided she liked Trump so she
has historic historic seeing where she
got the only apology that has ever
issued from Donald Trump's mouth because
he would always ask me when I was
interviewing and during the campaign if
your sisters still with me and after he
retweeted the mean picture of Heidi Cruz
you know an unflattering picture
compared to Melania I said to him you
lost my sister she thinks that was
horrible and offensive and he there was
a long pause and he goes he tried to
explain himself and I said stop there's
no explanation for what you did and so I
said why don't you just apologize and he
goes okay I apologize tell your sister
marina the first time you spoke truth to
power like that were you nervous oh I
was terrified when I was covering I
still AM I was covering the first
president Bush and my bosses unit east
of nighttime press conferences man and
my bosses gave me like a four-part arms
control question but I was too terrified
to ask it so I never asked a question at
a press conference or in a gaggle and
finally President Bush decided he was
going to ask me a question of Chris but
he never did yeah it's scary but you
know there's an old saying a cat can
look at a king so you know we have to
we're and which I think people realize
more than ever now an important part of
the democracy where we're you know we
are the ones who tell people when
politicians have become drunk with power
and are doing things that can really
hurt the country and I take that role
really seriously the Year voting
dangerously the derangement of American
politics is the newest book by Maureen
Dowd and Timothy is in West Palm Beach
Florida
Timothy you're on book TV with marine
dad go ahead
hi I need to comment she came to West
Palm Beach in three years ago retag from
Washington I found that very few people
need anything or main thing we should
would have to apologize and let you go
neither of us can understand what you're
saying it sounds like you're on a
speakerphone so let's move on to Robert
who's also in Florida in st. Petersburg
Robert or listen hi I'm Maureen hi I'm
glad just glad to finally get you on the
phone because it is painful for years
and I finally got through I just wanted
to ask your questions only the craziest
first lady you ever met ah here here are
very question ah let me think about that
for a second um so you knew Nancy Reagan
para Laura Bush is lovely Nancy Reagan
was a very formidable woman she you know
as somebody said Ronald Reagan you know
might have been pumping gas if it
weren't for Nancy Reagan she was a she
was a great politician as is Michelle
Obama you know because they're in such
an antiquated white satin box of a job
you know you often can't see how great a
politician they would be themselves and
Michelle Obama for instance was always
urging her husband to be more visceral
in the debates and ministers
wants to thing which was great advice
because he would always fall into being
very cerebral and let me think what
other firstly you have Barbara Bush in
there Barbara neutron Barbara Bush is
wonderful and I sent if the Christmas
present to the Bush's a few years ago I
sensed a soundtrack to the movie 50
shades of grey that's a joke because
Bush has a president Bush is a wonderful
sense of humor
and Barbara Bush wrote me back and
they're thanking me and she goes I
haven't read the books I really don't
think you know it's my cup of tea and
you know as I say Greenwich Greenwich
and then well Hillary Clinton yeah
Melania Trump yeah Melania Trump is
lovely you know I met her on a 99
campaign trip with Donald Trump when
they were dating and I think she has a
very lovely very reserved or about her
and I think if she doesn't want to come
to Washington everyone should leave her
alone because she's a wonderful mother
and if that's her priority that's great
and it's a super antiquated job anyway
and people in Washington are kind of
like oh it's going to do the Easter egg
hunt you know well I hate to let you in
on a secret but the first lady isn't up
in a room dyeing Easter eggs and weaving
baskets I'm sure they can handle that
without her Hillary Clinton well Hillary
is half my book so you should get the
book because I start covering her in 92
when she is chasing at the very words
first lady and she wanted to be called
First Mate which sounds a little more
like a pirate stuff but you can see in
my stories and columns through the years
the evolution of how I feel about her so
I highly recommend my own book there
you refer to the White House during the
Clinton time there as motel 1600 well
yeah I thought it was very offensive the
way donors you know we're buying the
Lincoln Bedroom and Air Force One
and I think that money has always been
you know that grass penis has always
been a problem for the Clintons even now
that they have like 230 million or
whatever she still felt the need to do
six hundred seventy-five thousand worth
of Goldman Sachs speeches which is not I
mean at that point it's a psychological
issue she just clearly feels that they
have to keep stockpiling money maybe
because she was the breadwinner when
they got started in Arkansas James is
calling in from Loon Lake Washington
James her on book TV with marine down
well good day Maureen Dowd enjoying the
program I feel like I walked through a
lookingglass software around evening on
November 8th and have wondered what's
been going on I mean an alternative
reality all of a sudden and you know
there's a great deal of concern
regarding the amount of Russian
influence in our government for the
election and now how much is here to
stay how much has integrated itself into
the fabric of our government machine
because a great deal important people
seem to be ignoring it totally they
refuse to have shoes thank you let's
hear from marine down we've got Looking
Glass in the absent election James I
can't tell you the number of times I've
written the words looking glass into a
column and then taking it out because
I've used it so often and you're right
it's an alternative universe and like
bizarro world with alternative facts and
I have to tell you that the Russian
story is the strangest thing that my
colleagues and I have seen in our career
it's inexplicable
and you know they're going to have to
it's just strange to see the Republicans
twisting themselves into pretzels to try
and you know be aligned with Donald
Trump position in this bromance with
pretty food as Bush used to w used to
column that was his nickname for him but
w started out thinking that he could see
into Putin's soul and it's John McCain
said the only thing you see when you
look into Putin's soul or the words KGB
or letters KGB so I think it is a
bizarre bizarre a world situation with
this relationship with Putin and I think
we're going to have to have
investigations and get to the bottom of
Trump's relationship with the Russians
and his aides relationship with the
Russians and I agree with you 100%
you hear from your readers I
I am super super sensitive believe it or
not so it's hard for me to read you know
they can be very tough on chimes
columnist and it's funny because when I
let Kevin write my column he loves
reading the nasty comments he loves it
he frames them but it's hard for me I
think I would be just debilitated under
the pillows if I read all of them self I
don't I mean I would love to hear what
Times readers think if it was not
scatological
or you know
obscene but yet as you know the Internet
has course and of course and society and
it particularly his women on the
Internet so it's best for me not to see
all that stuff well Peggy Dowd wrote in
her chapter in the book about her
convertible top being slashed because
she had a Goldwater sticker on the car
exactly that's exactly right and things
obviously have only gotten more and more
divisive to the point where
relationships are breaking up over
trough you know siblings are not talking
to each other over Trump but I have been
used to my conservative family for so
long that were just used to each other
now the low point came during W because
I wrote seven years worth of columns
against the Iraq war and one time I came
to Thanksgiving and my older brother
Michael said to me you know if there was
a hurricane you'd blame it on W and then
there was Katrina and I did so I've
already been through low points now we
we just know each other
Craig is in Tulsa Oklahoma go ahead with
your question are coming from marine dad
Craig yes a pleasure to talk to you yeah
I just was looking at it from a
sociological point of view and I was
curious if you kind of examined it in
that way meaning this that you know I've
never been a person that supported any
kind of like pro man Pro women Pro
battle the sexes of any side I believe
in unity and people working together but
I think when Trump was elected and he
had to be elected by a lot of women as
well as men it seems like there was a
piece or a truce called in the sense of
saying not that men are in charge that's
not what Trump winning meant what it
meant was it's actually contrary to the
90s ideology it's actually okay for a
man to be strong and to lead it's like
it was it became okay now to be a man
I'm just curious logically what you
think of that yeah Oh Craig well my
second book is about gender politics so
I'm always paying attention to
and you know I think in a way president
term doesn't get enough credit because
he's revised all of these things that
were sort of phlegmatic he's revived
feminism he survives liberalism he's
revived the ACLU he's put new life into
journalism we have an actual newspaper
war now with the times and the post and
you know I think I I got into politics
covering Geraldine Ferraro and they
thought there would be a big wave of
feminist fashion that would help help
the ticket and there wasn't I caused a
lot of women afterwards and interview
them for a magazine piece and I think it
is just a mistake to think that women
are going to vote in a block like
african-americans do and young women
especially were a rude awakening to the
Clinton campaign you know when Madeleine
Albright and flurry Steinem went out and
it was like you you owe it to feminism
to vote for Hillary and they were like
no we don't we're going to vote for the
person or not going to vote you know for
a woman because she's a woman that what
feminism was meant to accomplish was
exactly what these young women were
saying to give them the right to vote
for whoever they wanted to not in
identity politics so I would suggest you
get my left two books because one of
them is all about exactly what you're
talking about
and you know that was the funny thing
about covering the campaign because it
was this like Billie Jean King Bobby
Riggs battle of the genders because
Trump was so almost like a caricature of
a macho man you know you just picture
him coming out of a steam room in Vegas
with Frank Sinatra in 1959 you know and
he had Mike Tyson and John King and also
his macho former fellows you know worth
his celebrities and then Hillary because
she hadn't pushed gender in 2008 was
really pushing gender in this caricature
way where everything was like a slumber
Oh slumber party with Lena Dunham and
Katy Perry
in ariana grande music and so it did
make a funny gender contrast marine down
previous books are called Bush world
entering your own risk and our men
necessary when sexes collide she won the
Pulitzer in 1999 for commentary and her
most recent book is called the Year
voting dangerously on the cover is that
the famous escalator from June 2015 that
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton are
coming down
that's so funny yeah we did the
escalator the gilt escalator but then
when Theresa May came to visit Trump you
know when he held her hand it sort of
came out that he's scared of stairs so
but I guess he's not scared of stairs
where he doesn't have to move on this
but it's a funny image the escalator for
someone who's scared of stairs
Tina Hollidaysburg Pennsylvania good
afternoon
yes good afternoon I just noticed that
Maureen was saying something about how
nice Melania is and what a nice person
to you and yet she's not living in the
White House and she's okay with that
however I've been wondering if
Republicans and other people also would
feel that way if Michelle Obama would
have done that seeing that she had very
young young girls and if the next person
that gets into the White House also had
a spouse who will just decide that's not
for me
well you know there are a lot of things
that if the Obamas had done it you know
I don't think they would have survived
look at you know when Sarah Palin's
family came into that Convention and you
know her daughter was pregnant and not
married I mean you know the Obamas had
to be like Caesar's wife that's the
first african-americans and Michelle was
very conscious of that and I think she
did a peerless job of having you know I
went with the Obamas to Cuba and I was
very proud to travel with them as the
president and first lady because they
represent and those girls are amazed
and they represented America so well and
I think Michelle Obama did a virtually
perfect job as first lady and I think
she knew as you know Fox and everyone
was saying that her performance was
equally important to his in terms of how
history would view him and I think she
was wonderful and I agree with you that
they were judged by you know a very
different narrow standards and they were
always conscious of that and from the
Year voting dangerously marine Dowd
writes that President Obama he made us
feel good about ourselves Michael in
Yucca Valley last call go ahead thank
you to c-span and missed down I have two
things one it seems to me that they were
all licking our wounds after the
election those of us who are to the left
it seems to me that all the pendants are
looking for the answers as to how could
this how could domicile possibly get
elected I think in my mind the elephant
room is it was personality was his dues
as it was his celebrity mates it was
what people today because of the median
because of our access to quick
information and instant solution the so
they gravitate towards his personality
your Democrats don't seem to see that
that Hillary just didn't have that
dynamic personality and mainly it seems
to me and I'd like your opinion don't
don't the Democrats need in 2020 a
person with a incredible personality
like here's to win the second thing
we're almost out of time
I apologize we have to Michael I agree
with you a thousand percent I think the
Democrats ignored that at their own
peril in this age you know you can
already see all these celebrities like
Oprah and Mark Cuban and maybe George
Clooney are sort of and Howard Schultz
are circling around because they think
if that guy could do it I could do it
but I think the Democrats oftentimes
have nominated people with hall monitor
personalities like Al Gore
and Hillary and John Kerry and you know
people just couldn't warm up to them and
I think that was the margin of
difference and when you had a Bill
Clinton who had that big personality you
know that really helped him I agree with
you absolutely I don't know why they
never learned that lesson Maureen Dowd
first time taking calls on c-span sorry
very much appreciated her most recent
book is the year of voting dangerously
the derangement of American politics you
can read her in